well China is fighting back against
President Trump's decision to impose
those massive tariffs on their products
sent to the US and that leaves the
world's two largest economies on the
brink of a major economic conflict
correspondent Jillian Turner looks at
what that possibly could mean US farmers
are increasingly fearful that a
full-fledged trade war with Beijing is
on the horizon that includes Rob
Schaefer a fourth-generation soybean
farmer in Emory Illinois who also serves
on the board of directors of the
American Soybean Association I'm just
trying to make sure that we get it
through to you know the administration
as far as and I think I'm think they
understand it but I just make sure that
they understand how it's affected in the
people out in the Midwest and as far as
you know my bottom line China is now
threatening to impose its own
retaliatory tariffs on up to three
billion dollars worth of US imports and
American farmers caution that such a
move might incentivize competitors of
American companies to step in and grab
their business Brazil and Argentina okay
are willing and eager to take our share
of the Chinese market and once you lose
a customer it's awful hard to get them
back
China's commerce ministry is currently
considering a 15 percent tariff on
American exports to include dried fruit
wine and steel pipes plus a twenty five
percent tariff on pork and recycled
aluminum China is also drafted a list of
128 American products it would target in
the future should the US and China fail
to reach a bilateral trade agreement
we're losing 375 billion dollars with
China it could be five hundred and four
billion depending on the way you count
it's bad but the US isn't just battling
China in the traditional trade sector in
addition to the disputes over hard goods
such as steel and poultry the two sides
are now clashing over the tech sector
over the past two weeks alarming signs
of a major fallout have emerged the
Trump administration blocked China from
buying US tech giant Qualcomm a deal
worth 117 billion dollars and China
subsequently pulled its own
multi-million dollar investment from US
private equity powerhouse Blackstone our
society is dependent upon innovation in
ways that it hasn't been before but the
Chinese are taking the fruits of
innovation and they're stealing it in
ways which are predatory mercantilist
and completely unacceptable this ongoing
us-china tariff dispute underscores
Washington's latest worry that China
will displace America as the world's
innovation hub and that Shanghai or
Shenzhen may soon become the new Silicon
Valley
Brett Gillian thank you